hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
so they're gonna be talking about
something a little bit different today
it's gonna be about a patch that is just
good about to be going live today a very
small patch with a bigger patch coming
next week and then to something about
the borderlands showed that it might
have details about what's going to be
the dlc the very first dlc of
borderlands 3 not be free stuff that
we've been getting like the bloody
harvest event and then the upcoming
mallow on take down but the actual first
dlc that we should be receiving sometime
in the future so as well as like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
now let's get started so first stuff
we're gonna be going over the hot fixes
and of course remember that this stuff
is always in the description down below
so you can always check this out for
yourself after the video they said this
week's borderlines 3 hotfix will be live
on all platforms by 3:00 p.m. Pt D today
so roughly about 6 p.m. in my timezone
being in the EST so whatever you happen
to be honestly it's like - it's like 2
o'clock at the moment the time I'm
making this video so it honestly should
be live by the time that you're watching
this a small patch like I said there's
probably one actual thing in here with a
lot of them being bug fixes some of them
being reported concerns where players
couldn't hear reales holographic
doorbell into the door some of them
hearing concerns where some players were
missing the way point when quitting out
of a map or performing a save loading
during the bad reception side mission so
very specific bugs that they're going to
be fixing which is cool like the screen
shaking went in a party when one player
uses bear fish duplicated audio with
Maya when it went in beneath the
Meridian the actual thing that is a
patch and not just a small bug fix is
that they lower the chance to see
haunted enemies outside of heck this is
for the bloody harvest event a lot of
players were concerned that they didn't
because they were so sick of trying to
grind and they would have all these
haunted enemies and if you are unaware
if you kill a haunted enemy then skulls
will pop out that being a badass skull
loot skull or just a regular skull in
general so that would actually prohibit
the player from actually having a lot
more fun with grinding and stuff like
that so they lower the chances of them
seeing Haunted enemies outside of it
they're still going to be some but it's
not as much as before and obviously with
a little road map reminder that the new
content the mellow one take down at
black site is going to be coming up I
think we actually within a week of my
think what it's November 14th today so
it might be November 21st 22nd something
like that so it's very very close so one
this is going to be out as well as
releasing mayhem for so and a lot of
other things are gonna be happening for
especially the console players with the
screenshot footage and stuff like that
so there's gonna be some crazy stuff
that we're gonna be getting especially
in this November patch
well first has to do with Borderlands
first ever official DLC and this is
gonna be on November 20th now this isn't
going to be when the DLC goes live we
don't actually know if it's going to go
live that day but I'm fairly certain
it's not going to this is an episode of
the Borderlands show hosted by a couple
other very popular celebrities within
like the gaming scene and then the CEO
and the president of gearbox software
Randy Pitchford is gonna be here and all
that's all these people are gonna be
talking about the Borderlands update and
on the borderline show and in the
thumbnail it has a picture of Jack's
face and a type of city Eska look in
this picture and the first thing I think
of and maybe a lot of other people that
played Borderlands 2 think of is
opportunity an opportunity is a area in
Borderlands 2 where you first meet the
clone of Jack you need that to get
Jack's recognition software in order to
get to the bunker so you can rescue
angel and all that other [ __ ] in the
borderlands story if you haven't played
it definitely go do it's actually such a
great game person in my favorite way
better than three but I'm just maybe I'm
just a bit biased there but they say on
Wednesday November 20th the full reveal
trailer for DLC 1 will be making its big
debut at 8 a.m. PST at the exact same
time this goes live the third episode of
the Borderlands show will kick off to
deliver more insight on the borderlands
through first campaign DLC that's
launching later this year so that
essentially means that it's probably
going to release early or mid December
seeing as we're getting mallow on take
down somewhere in November to the letter
urging at the end of November this will
either be early December or midway
through December and besides the DLC 1
goodness that they're gonna be looking
at throughout this show they're gonna be
looking at the huge patch that's coming
with the malla wanna take down event
that mayhem forward the quality of life
improvements and a lot more content
coming forward so don't worry I'll be
updating you guys on all that stuff when
it goes live like I said it's gonna be
on November 20th so be on the lookout
for that if you can't make the dev
stream as for what exactly like I said
specifically I think that this DLC will
entail I have no idea I'm actually like
I said I'm super interested to see how
this plays out cuz honestly jack is dead
I'm not really sure what's gonna be
going on with that and that I think just
makes this even more exciting yeah
hopefully guys like that video like the
view did though and I'll see you guys on
xx so we could talk about more about
this new DLC and the upcoming free
content mellow on take down peace out
guys have a greater day and goodbye